بين دفتي كتابه يرمي بحجاره الامير هاري
يفتخر بقتله 25 عنصر من طالبان وتاره اخرى
يؤنبه ضميره على المدنيين الافغان كلمات
ناريه اطلقها هاري عن تفاصيل فوضه حرب
افغانستان اكثرها لسعا قوله انه كان يرى
المستهدفين كقطع شطرا يقصها من فوق الرقعه
كانت مهمته تصويب الهدف على متن مروحيه
اباتشي الهجوميه يروي هذه المقاتل حقبه
المعركه دون ان يعيا ان تلك الرصاصات
مرتده وان طال الزمن
ليست ممن حاربهم وانما ممن كان بينهم
المحاربون القدامى ردوا عليه
الكولونيل المتقاعد ريتشارد كم بيتهمه
بالخيانه
[موسيقى]
وقال انه مخطا وما سرده لا يمثل حقيقه
الجيش البريطاني لان الحرب لا تعني التجرد
من الانسانيه بل انهم يحترمون مبادئ
اتفاقيات جنيف
يتابعكم بماثر الجنود تفضلوا اطعام
الجائعين في العراق على ان ياكلوا في ساحه
المعركه
سخيف ومظلل اوصاف يكتبها البريطانيون على
ظهره هاري
انها نوع من الاحتلال الماساوي لكسب المال
عشر سنوات فكيف له ان ينقلب الان